bonsoir bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver
dans sa vous regarde ce soir un
économiste dans le fauteuil du grand
témoin Nicolas Bouzou bonsoir vous
publiez la France de la peu près aux
éditions de l'Observatoire un essai
tonique sur l'excellence que les
Français attendent mais sans s'en donner
les moyens un essai à rebrousse poil
aussi en pleine crise des retraites où
l'on parle travail mérité et fort vous
avez des solutions vous nous les ferez
partager tout à l'heure mais on commence
avec notre grand débat ce soir quel
bilan de la loi clesses Leonetti sur la
fin de vie sujet douloureux intime et
universel les députés s'en sont emparés
pour évaluer très concrètement
l'application de cette loi de 2016 dans
les hôpitaux du pays ils rendaient leur
rapport aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée on en
parle dans un instant sur ce plateau
avec nos invités et puis 20h15 bien sûr
les partis pris de nos affranchis et le
bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'ASSE lée vous me suivez Nicolas Bouzou
ça vous regarde plus partie
[Musique]
c'est l'ultime demande d'une personne en
fin de vie mourir paisiblement mais
est-ce vraiment la réalité du terrain
est-ce qu'on meurt mal aujourd'hui en
France en 2023 et cela à cause de la loi
c'est à cette question difficile qu'on
lui réponde les 19 députés de la mission
d'évaluation de la loi classique
Léonetti votez en 2016 bonsoir Olivier
Fanny bonsoir c'est vous qui la présidé
cette mission à l'Assemblée députée
modem de Charente-Maritime vous militez
pour l'évolution de la loi on le sait on
se souvient de votre texte sur l'aide
active à mourir qui ouvrait la voix au
suicide assister à l'euthanasie on en
parlera sûrement mais c'est pour évaluer
cette loi que vous avez travaillé
notamment avec vous Didier Martin
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'être là vous
êtes député renaissance de Côte-d'Or et
co-rapporteur de cette mission
d'évaluation sur la fin de vie et puis
deux soignants deux médecins sur ce
plateau professeur Antoine Laffont
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être là vous
êtes cardiologue vous dirigez l'unité de
cardiologie interventionnelle
capital Européen Georges Pompidou à
Paris enfin bonsoir docteur Anne Vivien
bonsoir merci d'être là ancienne
anesthésiste et réanimatrice des
hôpitaux de Paris vous êtes la
vice-présidente de la DMD l'Association
pour le droit à mourir dans la dignité
Nicolas Bouzou s'est un sujet qui nous
concerne tous c'est un sujet important
un sujet grave et également d'ailleurs
la convention citoyenne rend ses
conclusion ce week-end n'hésitez pas à
intervenir quand vous le voulez alors
avant de savoir si elle est bien
appliquée cette loi qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit laisse Leonetti la 200 secondes pour
nous la résumer le chrono de Plato pour
commencer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir bonsoir Stéphane toutes
et tous alors puisque on parle de fin de
vie bien commençons par rappeler la
promesse qu'avait fait le candidat
Macron c'était il y a un an quand il
présentait son programme à la presse on
l'écoute je soumettrai la fin de vie à
une convention citoyenne et sur la base
des conclusions de celle-ci à ce
moment-là je soumettrai où à la
représentation nationale ou au peuple
le choix d'aller au bout du chemin qui
sera préconisé le candidat est devenu
président ça tout le monde est au
courant et la promesse est tenue puisque
ces trois derniers mois une convention
citoyenne s'est effectivement réunie
pour faire des propositions sur ce thème
de la fin de vie il y a eu des votes qui
ont déjà été faits trois quarts des
citoyens était favorables à l'idée
d'inscrire l'aide d'activer à mourir on
va dire le tanazi dans la loi ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui mais comme
vous le disiez avant de faire une
nouvelle loi comme on aime bien faire en
France faudrait peut-être déjà savoir si
celle qui existe est efficace donc une
mission parlementaire nous avons ici un
des rapporteurs c'est penché sur la
question et en fait
l'un des objets principaux de la loi
classe leetti du nom des rapporteurs de
cette loi là l'objectif principal
c'était de permettre à tous les Français
sur l'ensemble des territoires d'avoir
accès aux soins palliatifs on va dire
pour résumer que en France les gens ont
droit de ne pas mourir dans d'atroces
souffrances or le problème c'est que
cette loi a été adoptée il y a 7 ans et
qu'elle n'est pas respectée faute de
moyens c'est ce qu'a expliqué ce matin
Caroline Fiat qui est
réfléchir à ce qu'on va dire ce que on
veut réanimer après un arrêt cardiaque
est-ce qu'on va être un tube enfin vous
refuser d'être un tube et refuser d'être
nourri artificiellement donc le problème
c'est que seulement 13% des Français ont
rempli cette directive assistée qui
pourrait être utile dans les
circonstances ultimes et comprendre
parce que évidemment quand on est en
bonne santé bon c'est pas le moment où
on a le plus envie de penser à l'idée
qu'on pourrait finir dans des conditions
atroces et puis quand on est malade bah
on pense avant tout à guérir plutôt que
de commencer à faire régler les détails
de son agonie donc bref on arrive à
l'idée que la mort c'est quand même la
grande question qu'on met tous un peu
sous le tapis si bien que les Français
sont même pas au courant de la loi
actuelle je vous ai parlé de la
directive anticipée mais pareil pour la
sédation profonde on se rend compte
quand on fait une enquête que les gens
savent pas forcément ce que c'est et
pourtant et pourtant c'est quand même au
cœur du débat qui va se poser parce
qu'actuellement on fait donc une
sédation profonde ça veut dire qu'on
autorise les gens qui endormir
profondément jusqu'à la mort les gens
qui vont mourir mais la question
qui va se poser c'est est-ce qu'on
autorise le thanazisme c'est-à-dire les
gens qui veulent mourir j'ai repris la
distinction faite par Didier Martin on
écoute tant qu'il explique ça ce matin
en confiance de presse cette loi
classique elle était conçue elle était
rédigée pour ceux qui vont mourir dans
les jours à venir très précisément dans
ce cadre-là avec bien sûr
une souffrance qu'on ne peut pas apaiser
avec bien sûr un pronostic vital et une
maladie incurable la question de l'aide
active à mourir se posera pour ceux qui
veulent mourir c'est-à-dire ceux qui ont
un pronostic qui est au-delà de ce
quelques jours
alors j'ai fait de mon mieux pour poser
le débat j'ai peut-être un peu simplifié
que vous allez pouvoir préciser
n'hésitez pas à expliquer à expliquer
encore parce que c'est quand même plus
compliqué que être juste pour ou contre
le tanaisiste
d'accord sur sur le sujet Olivier
falloir dit déjà comment vous expliquez
qu'aucun bilan n'ait été fait de cette
loi qui a été votée il y a 7 ans je ne
me l'explique pas et je trouve ça
totalement anormal d'ailleurs de façon
générale le législateur n'évalue pas
assez les lois qu'il vote mais en
l'occurrence en l'occurrence 7 ans de
réflexion c'est un peu long donc il y a
eu des évaluations fait par d'une part
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales d'autre part le Conseil d'État
qui ont été faites toutes les deux en
2018 c'est-à-dire de manière
probablement trop précoce pour le coup
et mais il n'y a pas eu la moindre
évaluation parlementaire de cette loi
donc je pense que nous répondons
vraiment à un bon traitement est-ce que
c'était facile à faire ce travail
d'évaluation est-ce que les données
exige sont accessibles est-ce qu'il en
existe alors d'abord c'était passionnant
et nous avons travaillé dans un cadre
apaisé serein qui contrastait beaucoup
avec ce qu'on vivait à côté dans
l'hémicycle sur les retraites et par
ailleurs nous avons effectivement
beaucoup de mal à avoir des données
quantitatives nous sommes en incapacité
de vous dire ce soir combien de sédation
profondes et continuent maintenues
jusqu'au décès sont pratiqués en France
chaque année parce que cet acte n'est
pas codifié c'est à dire que quand une
sédation profonde est pratiquée et bien
elle n'est pas mentionnée dans ce
répertoire qui indique tous les actes
médicaux qui peuvent être faits donc
nous sommes en incapacité de vous donner
un chiffre de sédation profondé continue
par contre ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que c'est sédation profonde qui sont
très différentes de ce principal
innovation de la loi classe Leonetti
c'est la principale innovation qui était
présentée comme la solution alternative
à l'aide qui va mourir et qui est très
différente des sédation habituelles où
on endort provisoirement on appelle ça
les sédation proportionnées là c'est une
sédation qui est irréversible puisque
comme son nom l'indique elle est
maintenue jusqu'au décès pronostic vital
engagé à court terme affection grave et
incurable souffrance réfractaire au
traitement je rappelle les trois
conditions évidemment si le malade le
demande c'est bien ça peut appliqué
c'est ce que je voulais vous dire on n'a
pas les chiffres mais ce qu'on sait sur
une base déclarative parce que tout le
monde me le dit nous le dit c'est que la
sédation profondé continue n'est pas
appliquée alors il y a deux raisons qui
sont parfois contradictoires et qui
marquent aussi peut-être une sensibilité
différente au sujet certains nous disent
nous ne l'appliquons pas parce que c'est
pas nécessaire
parce que cet outil là peut-être
utile mais vraiment en dernier ressort
en dernier recours et d'autres disent
comme Madame Lombard cette loi est la
sédation
profondeur effectivement émérite nous
dit cette loi n'est pas appliquée parce
qu'elle n'est pas applicable et que la
sédation profonde et continue pose plus
de problèmes qu'elle ne résout de
problèmes alors vous avez déjà dit
beaucoup de choses Didier Martin comment
peut-on résumer votre rapport sur
l'application de cette loi clés Leonetti
est-ce que globalement on peut dire
qu'elle n'est pas appliquée et qu'elle
est mal appliquée
alors je ne suis pas d'accord c'est une
question que je vous adresse
mal connue y compris par les
professionnels sauf certains parce que
c'est leur pratique quotidiennes en
particulier en réanimation mais la
plupart des soignants qui ont leur
éthique qui ont leur déontologie et qui
font pour le mieux pour accompagner y
compris dans unités de soins palliatifs
connaissent mais il n'y a pas eu de
grandes communication la formation
certes des soignants des aides-soignants
des infirmières des médecins comprend
des modules sur la fin de vie mais c'est
encore très insuffisant nous manquons
d'enseignants nous manquons de
chercheurs sur la question de la fin de
vie ces études ne sont que trop peu
nombreuses il faut vraiment chercher
dans les publications pour savoir
comment se passe la sédation profonde
continue donc elle est plutôt peu
appliquée plutôt que plutôt peu
appliquée alors professeur Anto profond
on va venir à la question de la sédation
profonde et continue jusqu'au décès qui
est le la pierre angulaire de cette loi
et on voit bien que sur le terrain les
soignants ont des doutes et sont
réticents vous montrera à reportage déjà
inégalité d'accès des soins palliatifs
la faute à qui la faute à quoi alors je
pense qu'il faut quand même rappeler que
on vit dans l'hôpital en tout cas
l'hôpital public
une crise majeure
des soignants qui
faute de d'avoir des conditions de
travail épouvantables quitte l'hôpital
c'est leur façon de faire grève et donc
ça c'est irréversible on peut dire que
c'est là on est un peu dans le la mort
programmée de l'hôpital et si on enlève
ceci on peut se poser des questions mais
c'est un élément majeur quand une
infirmière à 12 malades à sa charge puis
ça va donner 20 et puis 28 mais elle n'a
même pas le temps de s'adresser y
compris en soins palliatifs qui n'existe
pas dans tous les des services qui
n'existent pas dans tous les
départements il faut le rappeler ça
c'est la première raison la deuxième
raison c'est que
encore une fois je ne suis pas un
spécialiste des soins palliatifs je me
lève plutôt la nuit pour essayer de
lutter contre la mort mais
les le problématique des soins
palliatifs je pense que il y en effet
une parmi les soignants il y a une
réticence je dirais à l'ambiguïté et je
pense que ce qu'il faut rappeler dans la
loi laisse Leonetti c'est que la
première intention n'est pas de tuer
mais d'après d'apporter une fin
avec des soulagements notamment et
surtout au niveau de la douleur laissez
mourir à toute dernière
ultimeur plutôt que faire mourir si on
pouvait résumer les choses comme ça
c'est alors Anne Vivien on va parler de
la sédation mais je voudrais parler
aussi il y a d'autres éléments on a
parlé des soins palliatifs tout le monde
est d'accord pour les renforcer deux
tiers des Français qui ont pas accès
c'est énorme les directives anticipées
la DMD pousse pour faire cette directive
anticipées on n'est pas encore ça reste
très marginal oui ça reste très marginal
alors je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
raisons c'est d'abord parce que
effectivement la mort est un tabou en
France donc on en parle pas et parler de
ces directives anticipées même en
famille c'est très difficile donc ça
c'est une première raison la deuxième
raison c'est que c'est une notion qui
est assez difficile à s'approprier
parce que on sait tous que on ne connaît
pas notre seuil de tolérance à la
souffrance à la maladie tant qu'on n'y a
pas été confronté donc écrire sur le
papier ce qu'on veut ou ce qu'on ne veut
pas précisément tant qu'on est en bonne
santé c'est très difficile donc moi
quand j'en parle les miennes sont
rédigées et j'en ai parlé autour de moi
mais quand j'en parle je dis toujours
n'oubliez pas que ces directives
anticipées sont faites uniquement pour
le cas où vous ne pouvez pas vous
exprimer
sinon tant qu'on peut s'exprimer c'est
directives anticipées elles sont dans un
dossier mais c'est pas celle-là qui
servent à prendre aucune décision
c'est tant qu'on bon donc elles ne sont
intéressantes et importantes que dans
très peu de cas mais des cas qui sont
sensationnels comme celui de Vincent
Lambert donc toute personne jeune en
bonne santé peut un jour
accidentellement ou par une maladie
foudroyante se retrouver dans
l'incapacité de dire ce qu'elle veut
tout en étant dans un état incurable
et donc c'est dans ces cas là que les
directives anticipées sont très
importantes vous pensez que les gens qui
les font ont vraiment confiance dans le
respect de ce document là où se disent
attention le médecin ne va pas forcément
m'écouter exactement c'est la deuxième
raison pour laquelle il y a si peu de
personnes qui les rédigent c'est qu'il y
a des tas d'exemples ou
ces directives anticipées ne sont pas
respectées bien là bien et la DMD a un
site à justement et les respecter et les
rédiger alors on rentre dans le coeur du
sujet on a compris la sédation profondé
continue jusqu'aux décès et rare dans le
pays une pratique qui semble voilà faire
hésiter les soignants le moment de la
décision venue illustration dans cette
unité de soins palliatifs en région
parisienne où vous êtes rendu tous les
deux messieurs les députés c'est un
reportage de Céline Crespy et Gilles le
peintre
hôpital de Juvisy en région parisienne
ce jour-là le service des soins
palliatifs reçoit deux députés pour une
visite un peu particulière notre rôle
c'est évaluer l'application de la loi
klessonetti d'en voir les failles
éventuelles pour les soignants mieux
appliquer la loi serait d'abord d'en
avoir les moyens sur le papier de
médecins sont dans le service mais en
réalité il n'y en a qu'un
idem pour les infirmières
quand tu es arrivé ici il y avait
beaucoup plus
de il y avait aucun patient qui
décidaient seuls maintenant quand il y a
un patient qui est en train de partir
c'est difficile de se détacher
parce que la collègue reste toute seule
pour 10 patients
en phase terminale la loi classe
Leonetti permet la sédation qui consiste
à endormir le malade sans le nourrir ni
l'hydrater jusqu'à la mort
est-ce que vous pratiquez régulièrement
ou pas
ce nouveau droit qui est celui de la
sédation profonde jusqu'au décès
une souffrance on est obligé
à un certain stade de passer au pratique
de l'acidation
l'acidation est un laissé mourir son
permettre le faire mourir une frontière
que ne se voit pas franchir les
soignants opposés à l'euthanasie c'est
pas à moi à donner la mort à quelqu'un
alors que moi j'ai signé pour prendre
soin de l'autre et pas pour le faire
mourir peut-être que la loi évoluera
vers suicide assisté pourquoi pas les le
lieu des soins palliatifs en tout cas
l'hospitalisation sont qualitatif ne
sera pas forcément le lieu
les professionnels en sont un palliatifs
ont toujours combattu l'aide active à
mourir une opposition qui n'a pas lieu
d'être selon le député s'il devait y
avoir une loi
ouvrant le droit à l'aide d'activer à
mourir pour autant il faudrait si j'ose
dire dans le même temps
conforté et renforcée
l'accompagnement en soins palliatifs en
donnant des moyens humains et financiers
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé en
Belgique quand le pays a autorisé le
thanazisme il y a 20 ans il a aussi
renforcé ses services de soins
palliatifs
Martin on voit que c'est très très
sensible et très compliqué pour les
soignants très clairement réfractaires à
l'aide active à mourir ses soignants
soient palliatifs estiment ça n'est pas
leur mission donner la mort n'est pas
soignée mais y compris sur la sédation
on sent que c'est difficile alors on n'a
pas le chiffre mais on a l'impression
que c'est rare pourquoi alors sur le
chiffre dans cette unité dit
d'hospitalisation soit palliatif environ
200 patients par an et d'après le
médecin que nous avons interrogé deux à
trois sédation profondes continue
jusqu'au décès donc une pratique rare et
comme le dit cette infirmière leur
vocation effectivement d'accompagner de
veiller au confort de veiller au
bien-être de donner les médicaments et
d'aller jusqu'au bout
effectivement quand un patient elle dit
va partir il monopolise beaucoup de
notre temps et il n'y a plus qu'une
seule de nos collègues pour le reste des
9 autres patients
le réclame quand les critères sont
réunis qu'est-ce qui se passe
concrètement dans les hôpitaux de France
elles sont pratiquées on entend dire que
parfois la mort est lente et que ça
devient insupportable pour les familles
que elles durent parfois plusieurs jours
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe qu'avez-vous
compris
d'abord ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
la sédation profonde et continue n'est
possible selon les termes de la loi que
si le pronostic vital est engagé à
courte échéance c'est à dire sur
quelques heures maximum quelques jours
la principale difficulté à mon sens
c'est qu'il n'y a pas la maîtrise du
temps c'est à dire que il y a une double
angoisse d'abord parce que c'est une
sédation qui a vocation être
irréversible donc il faut pas que le
malade se réveille ça a pu arriver et ce
qui rend difficile d'ailleurs la
sédation profonde et continue à domicile
alors que ça devrait être possible dans
les faits ça allait difficilement parce
qu'il peut pas y avoir un suivi
permanent et puis par ailleurs la
maîtrise du temps que vous évoquez le
Conseil d'État en 2018 vous évoquiez
cette première tentative d'évaluation à
cette phrase il parle de mourant qui
n'en finit pas de mourir c'est terrible
cette phrase que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que quand vous faites une sédation
profonde et continue effectivement vous
endormez la personne la dans un coma
vous arrêtez de l'hydrater vous arrêtez
de la nourrir et finalement après tout
dépend de la capacité de la personne si
les organes vitaux tiennent le choc ou
pas et ça peut durer effectivement assez
longtemps combien de temps
c'est difficile de le savoir parce que
ça dépend effectivement une semaine plus
il y a des cas Vincent Lambert il a il a
eu une sédation profonde enfin pas
continue jusqu'au décès mais une
sédation profonde qui a duré un mois
avant oui un mois avant que les parents
avant que les parents dans un premier
temps avant que les parents n'obtiennent
que on arrête cette sédation
comme il y avait comme il n'était pas
d'accord voilà alors il a quand même été
mis en sédation profonde en principe
continue jusqu'au décès et puis le temps
que les parents
attaquent cette sédation il s'était
écoulé un mois et au bout d'un mois on a
arrêté la sédation parce que les parents
avaient gagné Olivier Olivier Martin je
vais vous livrer un témoignage que nous
avons eu lors de notre visite à
l'hôpital de Saint-Denis votre équipe
LCP nous suivait d'ailleurs et un
réanimateur en néonat nous a expliqué
que pour la première fois il avait fait
une sédation profonde et continue sur
bien un bébé en attalogie et cette
sédation profondé continue durée à la au
moment où il nous l'a évoqué déjà depuis
huit jours
imaginez ce que vivent les parents
en se disant cela fait huit jours que
notre bébé est en sédation
là elles sont à bout en France pour les
familles il faut comprendre que c'est un
corps qui s'assèche aussi sans
alimentation et sans nutrition c'est
effectivement une situation très pénible
très douloureuse c'est un déchirement il
faut pas le nier ce qui est pas une
limite éthique aussi nous avons une
équipe qui a pris une décision dans une
discussion collégiale soit la demande
d'impatient quand il était conscient au
moment où on a mis en oeuvre à la
sédation soit avec des directives
anticipées et là encore une discussion
collégiale et puis il y a des
préconisations pour ne pas dire des
protocoles avec des drogues qui sont
administrées et on doit vérifier tout au
long de la sédation la réaction à la
douleur l'éveil éventuellement mais se
pose des questions
encore l'activité cérébrale dans ces
conditions
on ne le sait pas c'est pour ça que nous
avons dans notre rapport préconisé que
cette sédation doit être adaptée aux
circonstances sans rentrer dans les
protocoles sans évoquer les questions de
temps et de délai mais dire et sécuriser
la pratique des équipes soignantes quand
la décision est prise il faut aussi que
cette sédation soit je dirais adapté et
efficace professeur Antoine Laffont puis
je vous ferai réagir Nicolas Bouzou
est-ce que ça montre pas que là en fait
on n'est pas on n'est pas dans la bonne
situation est-ce qu'il ne faut pas tout
simplement pour respecter la volonté du
malade après tout la question de savoir
si ça mordit appartient se pose rendre
les choses plus vivables pour ces choses
dire enfin en tout cas rendre les choses
plus rapides
alors toute la problématique moi ça m'a
fait froid dans le dos mourant qui n'en
finit pas de mourir du Conseil d'État en
tant que soignant sa glace le sang je
trouve
on impression que mais enfin vous
devriez être déjà mort que fait comment
se fait-il que vous soyez encore là on
rentre dans
dans l'absurde
encore une fois moi le problème de la
voix
absolument le Conseil d'État n'aurait
pas dû l'écrire et je pense que le fait
de bien préciser qu'il le faut pas
hydrater le patient on sait que la
déshydratation est source de souffrance
donc on peut pas à la fois dire on
soulage mais attention donc la question
que j'ai envie de poser finalement
cette adaptation la loi Leonetti
quelle est l'intention première
l'intention est de
t'apporter une
mort programmé vous vous étiez déjà
contre la loi classe Leonetti je
comprends ça
pique et qui s'applique parce que nous
avons des comment dire des une
des équipes mobiles de la
de soins palliatifs et qui et qui font
qui installent leur protocole
on n'a pas on n'insiste pas des des
patients qu'on regarde déshydratés si on
applique si on appliquait la loi même
classe néothétique il s'agit comme vous
le disiez de patients qui sont au bord
de la mort
mais le dire on arrête
l'hydratation moi ça me paraît absurde
quelqu'un qui est en train de mourir je
pense à tous les personnes qui n'ont pas
pu être intubé ventilés à cause du à
cause du covid préconisé
proportionné par donner leur 48 heures
ou parfois même quelques heures mais le
camembert est un cas tout à fait
exceptionnel d'une gigantesque tristesse
mais je pense ça n'était il rentrait pas
du tout dans le cas de la loi claire
mais c'est pas un cas unique
votre regard
la question de l'autonomie se pose à qui
à qui appartient ce droit à mourir dans
la dignité à la personne la société aux
familles ça appartient à la personne
mais moi votre débat que je trouve
honnêtement d'un niveau exceptionnel me
conforte quand même dans l'idée selon
laquelle il n'y a pas d'urgence à faire
une loi sur l'aide active à mourir et je
préfère déjà que on réfléchisse quand
même très en profondeur à ces questions
on sait que les lois sont assez peu
évaluées en France mais ce que disait
olivier falornique est quand même un
énorme problème c'est-à-dire qu'une loi
qui
est tellement touche un sujet tellement
sensible et qui concerne théoriquement
tous les Français qu'elle n'est pas
encore fait l'objet d'une évaluation
qu'elle fasse l'objet d'une évaluation
simplement maintenant est un énorme
problème après moi j'étais très
favorable à la loi classique auditi sur
le papier en théorie je pense qu'elle
est je pense que la théorie est toujours
bonne et en fait voilà ce que je
comprends de nos échanges c'est qu'il y
a des difficultés pratiques la question
de la sédation mais aussi la question
moi je suis très sensible à cette
question des soins palliatifs on a un
sous-développement dans notre pays en
matière de soins palliatifs qui est un
énorme problème et pourtant Olivier
phare Learny le Conseil national
consultatif des tiques a rendu un avis
extrêmement prudent et mesurer et mais
qui dit qu'il existe des situations dans
lesquelles on est en fin de vie et où le
pronostic vital est engagé mais non pas
à deux trois jours à très court terme
mais à moyen court terme et pour ces
gens-là il faut la désactiver à mourir
vous êtes d'accord oui c'est un avis
important et qui était un petit coup de
tonnerre parce que jamais le Comité
national d'éthique n'avait envisagé la
possibilité
d'une aide activa mourir et il considère
qu'il y a une voie possible pour l'aide
d'activals
le comité d'éthique et là effectivement
c'était au saisie
la proposition de loi que j'avais
défendu en avril 2021 justement pour se
prononcer sur y a-t-il une voie éthique
pour l'aide activa mourir et il avait il
a dit et c'est la première fois que le
comité d'éthique se prononce de cette
façon que c'est possible selon certaines
conditions d'ailleurs conditions qui
étaient de certains malades en
particulier
la maladie de Charcot deux
problématiques qui se posent ce sont les
pronostics vitaux à moyen terme comme on
dit
ça peut aller jusqu'à six mois
ça peut aller jusqu'à 6 mois je vais
vous donner un exemple Paulette
Guinchard kunzler secrétaire d'État aux
personnes âgées sous Lionel Jospin avec
qui je de nombreux débats il y a une
dizaine d'années qui étaient totalement
hostile à l'aide activa mourir qui avait
fait des tribunes pour dire non à
l'euthanasie au suicide assisté elle a
une maladie neurodégénérative à
l'apprend héréditaire
elle demande une sédation profonde et
continue on lui dit madame vous ne
pouvez pas bénéficier d'une sédation
profonde et continue parce que votre
pronostic vital n'est pas engagé à court
terme alors qu'elle savait la façon dont
elle allait les mourir de façon terrible
parce que elle connaissait en Belgique
elle est partie en Suisse en demandant à
son mari et à sa meilleure amie de dire
il faut que la France légifère sur les
dactivent à mourir donc quand on est
confronté aux réalités et cette femme
connaissait parfaitement le sujet et
bien on peut vraiment se poser des
questions la question elle est très
importante c'est comment faut-il la
faire évoluer la loi et pour terminer
qui doit pratiquer le gest létale et là
c'est la grande question des soignants
qu'en pensez-vous pour terminer la
Suisse c'est l'aide le suicide assisté
avec une association et c'est le malade
qui décide et qui pratique le geste la
Belgique c'est le médecin à la demande
du patient qui doit faire le geste elle
vient pour vous moi je pense que ça
dépend des cas ça dépend des cas les
deux sont doivent être accessibles avec
des avec des des garanties mais
l'euthanasie ou c'est un médecin qui
pratique l'acte permet de supporter plus
longtemps tandis que le suicide assisté
dans ces cas de maladie
neurodégénératives par exemple et bien
les personnes sont obligées presque
d'anticiper en disant après je ne
pourrais plus avaler ou tourner faire le
geste nous ce que nous pensons c'est ce
que nous pensons à l'adnd c'est que dans
les deux doivent apparaître dans comme
une possibilité dans le terme aide actif
à mourir ça doit couvrir les deux
possibilités et quand ce geste médical
ou le geste de la personnalité mais que
même s'il s'agit d'un suicide assisté
nous pensons qu'en France vu nos
antécédents de soins d'habitude il
faudrait dans tous les cas la présence
d'un médecin même si c'est le même qui
vous avez le mot de la fin Didier Martin
merci
dans ce geste et un symbole très fort
évidemment un tabou il faut le
reconnaître ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est
que c'est la demande du patient lucide
capable de jugement dans une situation
que la loi précisera et une inversion du
consentement à savoir que c'est le
médecin qui compte tenu du contexte et
en fonction de la loi accepte la demande
du patient et là que ce soit lui qui
prenne le patient prennent directement
son son médicament ou qu'il y ait une
injection par une pompe électrique ou
par un geste
médical parce que c'est une décision qui
de toute façon dans son essence et dans
son exécution doit être médicale et bien
là je dirais les choses importent peu
même si le symbole est très fort
l'important c'est la procédure c'est dit
en tout cas la convention citoyenne rend
ses conclusions ce week-end d'un mot
vraiment le temps nous écouter des
basses à chèvre
on ne peut pas considérer que l'aide
active à mourir est un acte médical ni
même un soin je suis désolé je ne
pouvais pas ne pas le dire vous avez
totalement voilà bien fait de faire part
de cette parole là qui est très relayée
notamment dans le corps des soignants en
ce moment merci beaucoup on va suivre ça
de près en tout cas si un texte de loi
c'est pas avant la fin de l'année 2023
s'il y en a un la situation politique
est un peu compliquée vous le savez
merci beaucoup merci d'être venu
débattre sur LCP vous restez avec moi
Nicolas Bouzou dans un instant on va
parler de votre livre mais dans une
dizaine de minutes vous les voyez ils
sont prêts nos affranchis ce soir Carole
Barjon rejoint la grogne qui monte sur
la votation Dani dalgo sur les
trottinettes ce sera dimanche cette
votation à paris France - Allemagne avec
Richard Verly qui compare ce soir la
façon de faire grève dans les deux pays
et puis une pétition à l'Assemblée pour
supprimer la brave m ce sera dans le
bourbon express de Stéphanie Despierres
mais d'abord
la France de la peu près Nicolas Bozo
elle est dur cette expression c'est
votre titre il raconte ce qu'est devenu
notre pays à vos yeux moyens un peu
désansant que ce soit catastrophique
alors il y a-t-il encore des raisons
d'espérer on voit ça dans l'invitation
de Thibault Enoc et on en parle ensemble
juste après
si on vous invite Nicolas Bouzou c'est
quand cette période de contestation de
la réforme des retraites vous prenez les
Français à rebrousse poil nous nous
écharpons sur une réforme somme toute
bénigne qui aurait dû être accepté en
deux temps trois mouvements loin sans
faut Nicolas Bouzou et vous le regrettez
pour vous cette France de Gaulois
réfractaire gâchent son génie en
privilégiant le confort sur l'effort un
état d'esprit que l'économiste est
essayiste libéral que vous êtes
directeur d'un cabinet d'études dénonce
à longueur d'ouvrage votre dernier livre
identifie ainsi un de ces mots français
à vos yeux la culture de la peu près
regardez les erreurs que comme elle
administration c'est l'URSSAF qui ne
prélève pas le bon montant c'est la
sécurité sociale qui n'a pas pris en
compte le fait que vous avez déménagé
c'est aussi quelque chose qui scandalise
un grand nombre de Français à juste
titre le fait que les fautes
d'orthographe par exemple ne sont
quasiment plus sanctionnés pour un
discours que tu sois bâti sur
l'excellence que l'on ne tient plus pour
des raisons qui sont des raisons
démagogiques ce qui manque selon vous à
la France plus de travail et plus de
rigueur un adage que vous déclinez dans
de nombreux domaines santé école
économiques la faute est collective la
France dans son ensemble pratique cette
stratégie de la peu près une stratégie
de régulation des efforts de la
satisfaction à court terme du manque de
lucidité qui débouche sur un sentiment
de frustration relatif à des résultats
décevants pour sortir durant Nicolas
Bouzou vous prenez ainsi un changement
de mentalité moins de bureaucratie le
retour à la méritocratie et la culture
de l'effort vous appelez ainsi à
réformer le pays toujours et encore et
concluez votre propos par une mise en
garde politique l'avenir de la France ne
peut s'inscrire que dans deux directions
le pire incarner aujourd'hui par les
populismes de droite et de gauche ou
l'excellence
alors Nicolas Bouzou une question pour
finir le pire nous avons bien compris
mais l'excellence est Emmanuel Macron
réponse non d'ailleurs je le dis dans le
livre au fond moi je trouve que la
politique qui est menée depuis six ans
globalement elle va dans la bonne
direction je suis jamais dit c'est si
dernière année mais il faudrait faire
l'inverse là on fait n'importe quoi donc
je trouve que ça va dans la bonne
direction mais voilà les et alors là la
réforme des retraites c'est exactement
ça c'est-à-dire que c'est pas bien
préparé c'est à la fois sur le fond et
sur la et sur la méthode quand c'est
fait quand les réformes sont votées et
promulguées c'est pas très bien exécuté
et puis c'est pas évalué vous voyez donc
je pense que en fait on pourrait faire
beaucoup mieux donc on a lui qui
incarnerait cet excellence je trouve que
à l'apprentissage
la France
c'est pas le Danemark c'est pas
l'Allemagne c'est pas la Suisse c'est
une espèce de moteur à explosion à
l'histoire de France notamment dans le
domaine économique social dans
l'innovation etc donc c'est vraiment
l'alternance de période qui sont des
périodes absolument extraordinaires de
point de vue de l'innovation le Second
Empire la belle époque il y a un peu
plus de 100 ans le monde entier avait
les yeux rivés vers Paris pour voir
participe passé les 30 glorieux qui en
France ont été parmi les plus brillantes
du monde
occidental
c'est pas une chute la France c'est pas
un pays qui chute c'est formidable de
vivre en France il y a plein de choses
qui qui fonctionnent mais ça fonctionne
pas comme ça devrait fonctionner et où
est-ce qu'il me frappe beaucoup c'est
que nos concitoyens ils veulent toujours
l'excellence mais dans les résultats et
je comprends ça ils veulent des salaires
qui sont plus élevés ils ont raison ils
veulent un hôpital qui fonctionne mieux
ils ont mille fois raison une éducation
à celle qui fonctionne mieux ils ont
mille fois raison sauf que tout ça ça
tombe pas du ciel c'est c'est ça se met
pas en marche automatiquement
avec le quoi qu'il en coûte est-ce que
le déluge d'argent
à tout le monde entreprises comme
particulier ça n'a pas anesthésié notre
capacité justement à renouer avec avec
l'effort avec la production avec toute
une série de de choses qu'il faudra
faire pour rembourser je crois que vous
mettez le loi sur un point qui est
absolument essentiel moi j'ai soutenu le
quoi qu'il en coûte je pensais que
c'était absolument nécessaire mais je
vois bien aujourd'hui que le
gouvernement a du mal à en sortir mais
il a du mal à en sortir parce que la
France globalement a du mal à en sortir
et d'ailleurs quelque chose qui est
beaucoup revenu sur cette question des
retraites c'était au fond vous nous
embêtez vous voulez nous faire
travailler deux ans de plus pour faire
pour trouver 15 milliards alors que on
vient de cramer 300 ou 400 milliards
avec la avec la crise en fait cet
argument est un argument rhétorique il
vaut pas ils vont pas parce que on avait
une dette importante avant la crise
c'était un problème bon on a une dette
très importante après la crise et c'est
un énorme problème mais du point de vue
du narratif politique je vois bien cette
difficulté et vous avez raison on a
enfin je sais pas vous prêter des
pensées mais je pense en effet qu'on a
un peu anesthésié le pays mais justement
maintenant il faut dire regardez
on a formidablement protégé les
entreprises de concitoyens pendant la
crise
ça a forcément une contrepartie encore
faut-il que ça se soit audible on sent
bien que c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui de demander un effort aux
Français
au-delà il faut pas le faire au-delà du
quoi qu'il en coûte
la France a un modèle social qui prend
l'eau et ça n'a rien à voir avec la
pandémie ça monte à bien plus longtemps
et en même temps la France et le pays
d'Europe qui paye le plus d'impôts avec
des services publics qui sont pas au
rendez-vous pourquoi précisément et à
qui la faute alors prenons un exemple
concret l'hôpital par exemple l'hôpital
pendant longtemps on a dit il y a pas
assez d'argent à l'hôpital cette année
on va mettre plus de 100 milliards
d'euros dans l'hôpital donc c'est on
peut pas dire qu'il y a pas beaucoup
d'argent il y a de l'argent en revanche
on peut dire qu'il est mal utilisé que
l'hôpital est désorganisé qui a plein
d'inefficacité que c'est mal manager que
les gens sont démotivés qui partent etc
et ça c'est très exactement
l'accumulation d'à peu près c'est à dire
que on s'occupe pas des gens on s'occupe
pas des personnels soignants on met on
empile des normes de la bureaucratie etc
on a des directeurs de Puteaux qui ont
pas toujours été responsabilisés et bien
au bout d'un moment ça vous donne
quelque chose qui ne va plus du tout à
force d'accumuler les défauts et ben on
y est ce que aujourd'hui le livre la
France de la peu près c'est qu'on gros
nos politiques publiques nos dirigeants
saupoudres de l'argent public un peu
partout sans faire de véritables choix
les États-Unis par exemple investissent
massivement en amont à la création des
inégalités dans l'éducation dans
l'innovation dans la recherche pourquoi
nous on n'arrive pas à faire ça à
l'échelle européenne de façon massive je
peux vous dire un mot de l'éducation
parce que ça me semble être un sujet
absolument emblématique ça va pas du
tout l'éducation nationale aujourd'hui
évidemment il faut à la fois
augmenter rendre le métier d'enseignant
plus attractif financièrement donc moi
je propose une règle que j'ai appelé +
20 + 10 c'est à dire plus 20%
d'augmentation pour tous les enseignants
aujourd'hui et 10% d'augmentation du
temps du temps passé avec les élèves que
ce soit en classe ou ou en petits
groupes donc ça tout de suite tout de
suite et après il faut bien sûr
réorganiser l'enseignement pour faire en
sorte que ceux qui se qui travaillent le
plus qui travaillent le mieux évidemment
il soit plus valorisé que les autres
parce que dans tout le système public
aujourd'hui si vous travaillez
énormément si vous travaillez bien mais
en fait vous n'avez aucun avantage par
rapport à quelqu'un qui aucun système
aucun ne peut fonctionner comme ça alors
ce qui est très intéressant aussi c'est
que on l'a bien compris la bataille de
demain elle va se jouer sur les
innovations de rupture sur
l'intelligence artificielle sur la
numérisation du monde les semis
conducteurs d'un enjeu extrêmement
important à l'échelle de la planète vous
nous dites que cette bataille elle n'est
pas économique elle est géopolitique
en France il faut qu'on maîtrise
l'innovation en fait ça vaut pour
l'Europe on n'a pas de très grosses
entreprises dans le on n'a pas de Gafa
dans le numérique
dans la l'intelligence artificielle mais
même dans les biotechnologies on n'a pas
ça si vous voulez et ça c'est absolument
essentiel alors pour ça faut des un
marché du capital un peu comme le Nasdaq
aux Etats-Unis il faut des universités
qui collaborent avec le secteur privé ce
qu'on a pas il faut des très grands
centres de recherche il faut que les
chercheurs ils aient envie de venir en
France et là encore qu'ils aient les
conditions de travail exceptionnel et
puis de bonnes rémunération mais tout en
amont revient à ce que je dis sur
l'éducation faut aussi des enfants à qui
on enseigne les mathématiques etc donc
vous voyez c'est un ensemble de choses
mais pourquoi c'est très important il
faut remercier pour votre question c'est
pas qui économique c'est une question de
puissance moi j'en parle au diplomates
tous les diplomates me disent oui on a
perdu en influence on a perdu en
puissance mais si on réfléchit en
profondeur à ce sujet c'est parce que on
maîtrise pas suffisamment les sciences
parce qu'on maîtrise pas suffisamment
l'innovation et c'est ça qui a affaibli
la voie de la France au niveau mondial
et si comme moi vous êtes un patriote
pas quelqu'un qui se dit patriote en
permanence mais si vous êtes un vrai
patriote et que vous considérez que le
mais oui que le destin de la France
c'est d'avoir une influence sur le monde
entier parce qu'on a un message à faire
passer pour moi le message français il
est très important et vous dites il faut
qu'on renforce notre économie pas
simplement pour des raisons économiques
et pour des raisons qui sont liées à
l'idée qu'on se fait de la France qui
s'appelle vous êtes aussi très dur avec
les écologistes dans votre livre pour
eux sous couvert de lutte pour le climat
ils n'ont qu'envie que de mettre à bas
le capitalisme c'est c'est pas un peu
caricatural c'est absolument pas
caricatural il lutte pas contre le
climat ce qu'on a vu là à Sainte Soline
contre les policiers et je suis pas sûr
du tout qui s'intéresse au climat ils
veulent renverser la société mais ceux
qui un certain nombre de ceux qui disent
écologistes sont pas des écologistes
regardez beaucoup sont contre le
nucléaire alors que le nucléaire non
seulement c'est un c'était un point fort
de la France et en plus c'est une
énergie décarbonée en fait il
beaucoup plus le capitalisme et la
technologie qu'il n'aime la planète et
bah c'est dit on a bien compris que pour
vous la croissance reste le meilleur
carburant de la France face aux crises y
compris climatiques la France de la peu
près pouvoir d'achat santé éducation
industrie revenons à l'excellence point
d'exclamation vous restez avec moi
Nicolas vous c'est l'heure d'accueillir
nos affranchis pour leur parler petit
prix et vous vous faire réagir on les
accueille tout de suite
Carole Barjon
éditorialiste bien sûr Richard Wery du
quotidien suisse elle est manique Blic
merci d'être avec nous installez-vous
les amis on commence comme chaque soir
par Bourbon Express c'est l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée elle nous est
racontée ce soir par Stéphanie Despierre
bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir alors ce soir
je vais vous raconter l'histoire d'une
pétition à propos des braves hems les
braves m ce sont ces brigades de police
motorisaient chargées d'assurer l'ordre
dans les manifestations et d'arrêter les
casseurs elles ont été créées
rappelez-vous en 2019 lors du mouvement
des gilets jaunes et elles sont sous le
feu des critiques depuis la mi-mars pour
leurs interventions musclées dans les
cortèges contre la réforme des retraites
plusieurs enquêtes judiciaires sont
d'ailleurs en cours pour des violences
contre des manifestants alors quel est
le lien avec l'Assemblée nationale et
bien cette pétition qui réclame la
dissolution de ces braves M a été déposé
sur une plateforme de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est un site spécifique créé
en 2020 pour faciliter le droit de
pétition citoyenne alors l'auteur de la
pétition s'appelle
c'est un ingénieur informatique de 50
ans francilien militant du Parti de
gauche et de la France insoumise son
texte est une charge contre ces unités
de police mobile qui selon lui sont un
des symboles de la violence policière et
participent je cite à l'augmentation des
tensions alors comme sa pétition est sur
la plateforme de l'Assemblée nationale
pour signer il faut renseigner son
identité via France Connect cela évite
donc à priori les signatures farfelues
et tous les doublons oui et gros succès
ont déjà plus de 100 000 signatures pour
cette pétition oui un cap franchi en 4
jours seulement ce soir à 18h30 on était
à 182
000 signatures c'est un record pour
cette plateforme de l'Assemblée aucune
pétition n'avait franchi la barre des
100 000 paraphes jusque là le plus gros
score c'était 40 000 pour l'allongement
du congé maternité alors désormais cette
pétition a gagné le droit d'être en
ligne sur le site Internet grand public
si l'on peut dire de l'Assemblée
nationale bon il faut encore chercher un
peu il faut bien une dizaine de pratique
pour arriver à mettre la main dessus et
la commission des lois a nommé un
rapporteur chargé des pétitions il
s'agit du député renaissance de Gironde
Eric Puya écouté il nous explique son
rôle j'ai trois trois options la
première c'est le classer cette pétition
le considérer que voilà son objet n'est
pas un peu où on est venu pour la classe
deuxième c'est de leur envoyer à une
autre commission considérons que c'est
pas la commission des lois qui est la
plus compétente pour en débattre et la
troisième c'est de l'examiner en
commission ou de dominer l'objet de
cette pétition en commission
alors les décisions sera prise mercredi
prochain si la pétition est examinée en
commission les dépurités pourront
ensuite auditionner le ministre de
l'Intérieur et les premiers signataires
du texte d'accord alors il reste un
second cap à franchir pour cette
pétition oui les 500 000 signatures
Myriam c'est désormais l'objectif des
détracteurs des braves notamment des
députés insoumis qui soutiennent cette
pétition alors vu la vitesse à laquelle
le compteur grimpe ça ne paraît pas
inatteable mais attention ces signatures
doivent venir de 30 départements
différents et à ce moment la seulement
la pétition pourra éventuellement
déboucher sur un débat dans l'hémicycle
à condition encore que les instances de
l'Assemblée nationale ce qu'on appelle
la conférence du président donne leur
feu vert ça fait encore pas mal
d'obstacles mieux vous faire un texte de
loi directement une proposition de la
pour supprimer cette cette brave elle on
verra ce qui ce qu'il en est de cette de
cette pétition Carole les trottinettes
ce soir pourquoi pourquoi pas allez
c'est à vous parce que dimanche prochain
donc le 2 avril un référendum est
organisé par la mairie de Paris pour le
maintien ou pour la suppression des
trottinettes ce sujet concerne quand
même près de 2 millions de personnes
plus quelques milliers d'autres en
proche banlieue bon bien entendu en
organisant cette votation à Hidalgo
cherche aussi à corriger son image de
Sarine autoritaire qui décide de tout
toute seule mais ce n'est pas le sujet
principal c'est pas une bonne idée pour
vous cette votation se référendum oui et
non dans cette affaire de référendum il
y a la méthode et puis il y a le il y a
le fond sur la méthode je suis un peu
réservé parce que certes la société
demande davantage de participation les
citoyens veulent être consultés
directement sur ce qui les concerne
directement c'est c'est tout à fait
normal mais ce référendum a été décidé
très tard en janvier et la communication
sur ce sujet
ayant été extrêmement discrète beaucoup
de Parisiens ne savent même pas qu'il y
en a d'autre part il ne faut pas s'y
tromper cette votation comme dit Madame
Hidalgo est en réalité une simple
consultation il y aura seulement 21
bureaux de vote dans la capitale
à titre de comparaison il y en avait 900
bureau de vote pour les dernières
élections nationales législatives
présidentielles et puis le vôtre par
procuration est impossible du coup on
peut se dire que la participation va
être faible et que les résultats ne
seront pas forcément représentatifs de
l'ensemble de ce que pense l'ensemble de
la population parisienne alors
pouvait-elle faire autrement la mère de
Paris oui elle aurait pu assumer ses
responsabilités prendre elle-même les
décisions qui s'imposent notamment pour
faire respecter les règles de base et
les interdictions qui concernent les 400
000 utilisateurs de trottinette qui
roule à 25 km à l'heure à ce propos le
ministre de transport vient de
l'annoncer que les conducteurs de
trottinette devront avoir au moins 14
ans et non pas 12 ans comme c'est le cas
actuellement on se demande pourquoi il
l'a pas fait plus tôt quand on port
obligatoire du casque question qui est
quand même très légitime la décision est
remisée à plus tard dommage c'est bien
dommage car l'an dernier à Paris il y a
eu 400 accidents
460 blessés 3 morts donc on a
l'impression que voilà les règles sont
pas du tout respectées sont en hausse
constante donc on sait pourtant qu'il
est interdit de rouler à deux sur ses
engins interdit de porter des écouteurs
interdit d'en faire sur les trottoirs et
personne ne respecte ses interdits non
en effet parce que le problème de la
Mairie de Paris c'est qu'elle n'a pas de
moyens suffisant pour faire respecter
effectuer les contrôles et faire
respecter les règles parce qu'elle n'en
a plus les moyens compte tenu de la
situation financière de la Ville de
Paris c'est aussi un sujet donc il y a
plus il y a quasiment plus de contrôle
nixtention c'est constamment pour cette
raison qu'anidalgo a préféré se
prononcer à titre personnel pour la
suppression pure et simple les
trottinettes et consulter les Parisiens
qui jusqu'il y a peu de temps étaient
majoritairement opposés aux trottinette
bon tout ça est un peu dommage parce
qu'entre deux solutions extrêmes la
suppression ou l'anarchie
on peut on peut faire une régulation
mais en fait il faut dans ces cas-là
anticiper et sans donner les moyens et
ça n'a pas été fait merci Carole c'est
c'est la France de la peu près la
trottinette et cette votation pour vous
Nicolas Bouzou je pense que les
Parisiens vont voter pour l'interdiction
des trottinettes et je suis partage
votre vie c'est à dire que au fond on va
interdire quelque chose parce que on
n'arrive pas à le réguler et en fait
quand on y réfléchit mais c'est absurde
et vous allez nos concitoyens qui voient
ça ils se disent mais l'état de droit se
délite et puis il y a d'autres
infractions que vous n'avez pas noté il
m'arrive de circuler à vélo électrique
dans Paris mon vélo est à 25 km
comme le veut la loi et je suis assez
bizarrement doublé par des trottinettes
qui visiblement elles ne sont pas à 25
km/h donc tout ça est quand même pas
possible mais c'est sûr que quand on a
un endettement tel et puis quand on n'a
pas voulu de police municipale pendant
très longtemps bah après pour faire
respecter le droit c'est plus compliqué
on est toujours
avec la trottinette
sur ce sur ce plateau vous en faites pas
je suis bien compris le vélo pas de
trottinette jamais
la votation la votation c'est la Suisse
vous voyez avec l'influence et levétique
déborde de plus en plus
faire une comparaison qui s'y frotte s'y
pique France Allemagne de pays en grève
de façon de la faire alors effectivement
vous le savez on parle souvent sur ce
plateau du couple franco-allemand on
redit d'ailleurs à chaque fois que le
mot couple il est pas utilisé outre-rein
les Allemands ils préfèrent parler
tandem pour évoquer l'idée de deux pays
qui si possible essaye de d'aller dans
le même sens pour avancer ensemble et
bien nous avons eu lundi une
illustration des différences qui rendent
quand même très compliqué un tel tandem
je veux parler de la grève générale qui
a paralysé l'Allemagne ce 27 mars avec
immobilisation des trains et des avions
on a vu les images des gars vides ou des
aéroports complètement vide également
une paralysie qui avait été déclenchée
par les puissances syndicales allemands
qui réclament des hausses de salaire
pour compenser l'inflation ce qui n'est
pas nouveau d'ailleurs l'Institut
économique d IW a dit qu'il y a eu plus
de grève ces 10 dernières années en
Allemagne que dans les décennies
précédentes comme si les Allemands se
mettaient peu à peu à ressembler à leur
turbulent voisins français mais la
réalité en fait de cette grève elle est
à l'opposé oui les Allemands partagent
le sentiment de colère sociale
généralisé en Europe on sait aussi qu'au
Portugal en Grèce dans d'autres pays ça
bouge même si le taux de chômage en
Allemagne est le plus bas depuis le
début des années 2000 oui faire la grève
reste là-bas un argument décisif les 160
000 employés de la poste allemande
viennent de le prouver puisqu'ils ont
obtenu 11% d'augmentation au début mars
pour mettre fin à leurs arrêts de
travail mais non les grèves françaises
et allemandes ne se ressemblent pas ce
lundi par exemple les employés en grève
en Allemagne ont pour l'essentiel
manifesté sur leur lieu de travail ils
ont d'abord adressé leur revendications
ou patronat et pas à l'état et tous se
sont remis au boulot dès le lendemain
comme il l'avait annoncé
grève sans bloquer sans violence c'est
ça alors le blocage il y en a eu un
blocage sévère ce n'était pas du tout
une fausse grève vous savez la japonaise
avec un brassard pendant qu'on continue
de travailler les arrêts de travail ont
été d'ailleurs d'une redoutable
efficacité quantité de voyeur de
voyageurs ont dû annuler leur trajet
mais deux différents je crois surtout
dans le débat actuel mériterait d'être
rappelé la première elle tient à l'objet
de la grève en Allemagne c'était les
salaires l'objectif c'était de mettre la
pression sur le patronat sur un point
précis dans le but d'obtenir l'ouverture
d'une négociation collective et non pas
une revendication générale sur les
conditions de travail et bien sur le
système des retraites autre différence
on ne cherche pas à torpiller dans la
rue un processus législatif l'objet de
la grève de l'Allemande de lundi il
était social il était pas politique
alors bien évidemment il serait facile
de comparer la grève de lundi la dixième
journée d'action de mardi c'est pas ce
que je veux faire mais regardons juste
la question des revendications et des
médailles et si les syndicats le
patronat le gouvernement le Parlement
était en France davantage dans le rôle
respectif comme en Allemagne au premier
la négociation sociale pure et dure au
second les choix de société et les lois
après un débat en bonne et due forme
bref chacun dans son couloir avec ce
modèle allemand il y aurait peut-être un
peu moins de fièvre révolutionnaires à
tous les étages en France ah bah voilà
une solution elle est pour vous la
question la grève à l'allemande le rêve
français
et d'ailleurs et c'est parce que je suis
pour la retraite à 64 ans que j'aurais
que j'aurais soutenu la grève en
Allemagne parce que vous pouvez pas dire
aux gens travailler plus moi je veux que
les gens travaillent plus etc et gagner
moins c'est pas possible si les gens
travaillent faut qu'ils gagnent bien
leur vie il y a de l'inflation les
entreprise allemande elles font des
profits il faut qu'elles augmentent les
salaires donc je trouve que les patrons
font passer des fois sur les salaires je
trouve que les entreprises françaises
gagnent de l'argent doivent augmenter
les salaires plus qu'elles ne le font
aujourd'hui absolument je trouve que le
on a vu dans la restauration mais il a
fallu négocier pourquoi aujourd'hui on
traite des pieds elles le font pas parce
que elles ont peur de l'avenir parce que
on a un climat social qui justement est
quand même plus révolutionnaire
justement qu'en Allemagne donc on manque
de ce niveau de confiance mais non moi
je pense que les la question du partage
de la valeur d'ailleurs les syndicats
français pour le coup sont plutôt bons
sur ce sujet là il y a eu un accord qui
a été signé comme vous savez fin février
qui est assez astucieux mais la question
du partage de la valeur elle est
absolument emblématique plus de salaire
aujourd'hui c'est juste et c'est
efficace avec ces différences qui est le
rôle de l'État en Allemagne comme je le
dis syndicat et patronat discute
ensemble tous les deux ne se tournent
pas vers l'état en disant rien la
culture du compromis social à
l'allemande on y est quelques millions
par an pour les retraites c'est vrai
merci à vous pour laquelle on s'arrête
là c'est terminé merci à vous les
affranchez et Merci à VOUS Nicolas
Boudou d'être passé sur le plateau de
LCP très belle soirée documentaire qui
commence maintenant avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien à demain
[Musique]